immer mehr und immer modernere waffen
für die ukraine damit wächst die chance
dass sich das land gegen putin behauptet
es bleibt auch die gefahr dass der krieg
sich ausweitet vielleicht bis zu einem
atomkrieg diese sorge haben 28
prominente und schrieben deshalb einen
offenen brief an den kanzler aber auch
befürworter von waffenlieferungen haben
sich bei olaf scholz gemeldet geht
deutschland geht der westen mit seiner
hilfe zu weit soll die ukraine diesen
krieg gewinnen oder soll sie bald die
waffen strecken um den weltfrieden zu
retten unser thema frieden schaffen mit
noch mehr waffen fehler oder pflicht
zwei der briefeschreiber sind heute bei
uns die deutsche ukrainische publizistin
marina weisband
ranga yogeshwar wissenschaftsjournalist
der cdu-außenpolitiker norbert röttgen
nicole titelkopf friedens und
konfliktforscher rinn und
kevin kühnert spd generalsekretär sie
sind zu gast bei maybrit illner und die
begrüßte jetzt in dieser sendung
ausgesprochen herz nächsten los geht's
mit den nachrichten vom tage norbert
röttgen cdu außenpolitiker herr scholz
und herr steinmeier dürfen ihnen die
ukraine kommen muss man formulieren
offensichtlich dank für die schmerz und
einem besuch dort vom dienstag macht die
opposition jetzt die außenpolitik
die opposition ist teil der politik in
deutschland
elementare reisen ist kein privileg der
regierung und offensichtlich hat sich
wieder gezeigt dass es hilfreich war
übrigens auch die reise der drei
ausschussvorsitzenden hat etwas bewirkt
ich glaube sowieso nicht bestimmt auch
befangen dass wir eine dass außenpolitik
nicht mehr irgendwie weit weg ist und
darum ist die parlamentarisierung von
außenpolitik richtig und die opposition
soll ihren anteil daran haben wir haben
nicht die mehrheit aber wir bringen uns
verantwortlich ein das ist glaube ich
gut für alle damit haben sie den namen
friedrich merz umschifft aber der
oppositionsführer geschafft was vorher
nicht möglich war über viele wochen also
so wie es aussieht hat er dazu einen
beitrag geleistet
und das zellen empfangen hat zeigt ja
erneut das interesse der ukraine des
ukrainischen präsidenten dass er auch
den oppositionsführer parlamentarier
empfangen hat und dieses gespräch war
glaube ich sehr gut und es hat
wahrscheinlich so sieht es aus einen
beitrag dazu gebracht dass es jetzt
entlockt die blockiert ist in der
gesprächsebene zwischen dem ukrainischen
präsidenten und der deutschen
politischen staatsführung
bundespräsident und regierungschef
wenn da der oppositionsführer einen
beitrag zu leisten ist es eine glaube
ich großartige sache kevin kühnert
generalsekretär der
sozialdemokratie ist eine großartige
sache ist friedrich merz der türöffner
für den bundeskanzler und den
bundespräsidenten dieses landes ich
würde gern einen sehr geringen teil
dieser sendung heute auf die diskussion
von aber zumindest kurz natürlich ein
gutes recht dorthin zu fahren aber ich
glaube die behauptungen
diese dieses telefonat heute sein erster
linie seinetwegen zustande kommt es
schon eher eine kühne behauptung haben
die kollegen von ihnen noch heute schon
recherchiert dass das wohl doch eher mit
dem interview von olaf scholz am montag
beim zdf zu tun hatte dass danach die
diplomatischen mühlen im hintergrund
abgehandelt zu malen dass herr merz das
jetzt versucht auf seiner reise zu
machen gut dann muss jeder selber wissen
wie man sich da alles glauben sie dass
es gut ist dass das jetzt geschieht
glauben sie dass es auch nötig ist dass
der bundeskanzler in die ukraine reist
ich glaube erst mal vielen menschen in
deutschland und in der ukraine ist heute
ein stein vom herzen gefallen dass
dieses gespräch stattgefunden hat das
von beiden seiten betont wurde wie
konstruktives gelaufen ist und natürlich
ermöglicht das jetzt auch was das reisen
angeht anscheinend neue schritte der
bundeskanzler hat heute in einer
pressekonferenz mit dem tschechischen
präsidenten zusammen er bekannt gegeben
dass direkt zu beginn der nächsten woche
die außenministerin dann auch eine reise
unternehmen wird die
bundestagspräsidentin alle aufzählen
zeugenstand bis vor kurzem hätte niemand
aufzählen können jetzt kann man sagen
die bundestagspräsidentin reist jetzt
auch zum tag der befreiung in die
ukraine um der opfer des holocaust dort
auch zu gedenken und des zweiten
weltkrieges das sind schon gute zeichen
in diesen tagen und das miteinander
gesprochen wird das war auch vorher
schon der fall aber jetzt offensichtlich
auch noch mal in einer deutlich
konstruktiven atmosphäre
marina weisband ist uns zugeschaltet aus
münster in kiew geboren bei den grünen
eine engagierte autorin und publizistin
dieses landes frau weisband
das richtige zu entscheiden in diesem
land muss man dafür in die ukraine
gereist sein
tatsächlich berichten viele politiker
innen in europa die in die ukraine
gereist sind das
sieben noch mal mit eigenen augen die
realität sehen und das macht etwas mit
ihnen denn wir haben das glück sag mal
pauschal in deutschland in einer relativ
friedlichen welt aufzuwachsen und die
dinge auch zu diskutieren auf einer
ebene die von unserer realität ausgeht
wenn man dort ist vor ort und mit den
betroffenen redet dann hat doch mal ein
objektives bild weil man aus seiner
eigenen realität noch mal raus geht und
sieht was ist eigentlich vor ort los
leute berichten das ist etwas verändert
also ich glaube nicht dass diese reisen
sind los sind wer müsste und sollte als
nächstes reisen nach denen schon
genannten scholz makro wäre das eine
nächste wichtige reise initiative
natürlich sollte der bundeskanzler
unbedingt reisen und ich denke je früher
desto besser ich meine klar das ist
nicht die substanzielle hilfe die
ukraine tatsächlich bei der befreiung
hilft aber es ist ein wichtiges symbol
ich denke wir unsere länder sollten
verbunden sein sollten als demokratien
zusammenstehen nun gibt es eine große
diskussion nicht nur um das engagement
dieser bundesregierung die hilfe dieser
bundesregierung für die ukraine sondern
insgesamt die frage wie weit der westen
wie wir deutschland dagegen sorgt 28
prominente haben einen offenen brief
geschrieben an den bundeskanzler der hat
für empörung gesorgt aber auch beifall
geerntet
sie fürchten den atomkrieg
dass immer mehr waffen nicht mehr
sondern weniger sicherheit bedeutet
das jahr
keinerlei verständnis für diese art von
schritte bewegung die bereit war lieber
rot als tot war eines der schlagworte
sich der sowjetischen bedrohung zu
unterwerfen
40 jahre und zwei zeitenwenden später
ist die diskussion neu entbrannt immer
mehr immer schwerere waffen für die
ukraine
nein sagen schwarzer yogeshwar und co in
einem offenen brief an den kanzler
just als der die kehrtwende zu schmidt
vollzieht
derzeit gewalt völlig aus dem rahmen
gefallen die neuen fronten in der
debatte
petra kallies enkeln wird kriegsrhetorik
vorgehalten vom nachfolger eines franz
josef strauß
da wird mit einem moralischen rigorismus
vom krieg geredet und zum teil auch sich
in einen krieg hinein geregnet nur drei
tage später der chef der schwesterpartei
in kiew märz und den schulterschluss mit
präsident selensky dem mann der vor
allem eines von deutschland fordert
ranga yogeshwar ist uns zugeschaltet in
diese sendung einer der brief autoren
über die inhalte wollen wir
logischerweise reden in dieser sendung
ranga yogeshwar an den guten abend wir
haben kaum dass olaf scholz von ihnen
für seine zurückhaltung gelobt wurde
wahrgenommen dass er genau die abgelegt
hat und nun diese bundesregierung auch
schwere waffen und auch haubitzen
liefern will kam ihr brief zu spät
ich weiß nicht ob er zu spät kam aber
entscheidend dabei ist der brief da
hängt eigentlich darauf dass wir die
debatte um diesen konflikt erweitern wir
haben in den letzten tagen und wochen
eigentlich erlebt dass wir immer mehr
sozusagen in eine militärische rhetorik
hineingekommen sind dass wir immer mehr
überraschen reden und zu wenig über
verhandlungen und wenn man sich einfach
klar macht dass
letztlich das latente risiko einer
eskalation da ist zumal dann wenn
schwere waffen geliefert werden also es
gibt fachleute es gibt menschen die ual
harari der sehr klar sagt zum beispiel
wir befinden uns jetzt in der
gefährlichsten
situation einer nuklearen eskalation
seit der kuba-krise
dann muss man das ernst nehmen die idee
dahinter ist möglichst schnell den
konflikt irgendwo zu löschen und die
nicht noch soweit anzufeuern dass er
möglicherweise eskaliert in etwas was
glaube ich alle nicht wollen marina
weisband es gibt einen zweiten offenen
brief den haben sie
mitunterzeichnet als erst
unterzeichnerin warum es ist ein
gegenstück zu dem brief von ranga
yogeshwar unter anderem warum diesen
brief auf dem break
interessanterweise haben beide briefe
das gleiche ziel beide briefe möchten
frieden für die ukraine für die welt
beide briefe möchten den krieg so
schnell wie möglich beenden und möchten
seine ausweitung verhindern wir
unterscheiden uns aber darin wir
bestimmte faktoren einschätzen in
wieweit sie hilfreich oder
abträglich sind und meine argumente
dahingehend sind wenn wir sagen wir
dürfen der ukraine keine schweren waffen
von der ukraine darf nicht in die lage
geraten den feind zu vertreiben von
ihrem territorium
dann gibt es keinen frieden in der
ukraine wenn sie kapituliert wenn sie
irgendwelche gebiete an russland abtritt
dann sind das die gebiete in denen
vergewaltigt wird gefoltert wird in
denen zivilisten am ort werden in denen
es diese
filtrierung stationen
das ist kein frieden diktatur ist kein
frieden und es ist falsch dass die
lieferung von schweren waffen er dazu
führt zu einer ausweitung dieses
konflikts als ein nachgeben denn nicht
nur russland beobachtet
sondern alle autoritären recht alle
atommächte sehen oh ich muss nur jemand
mit einer atomaren eskalation und dann
kriege ich alles was ich will wenn ich
eine aggression kriege ich als
kompromiss 50 prozent auf die ich
anstrebe
das ist ein fatales signal für eine
globale rechts wir erhöhen unsere zeit
wenn wir eine klare grenze erste frage
nochmal zurück an ranga yogeshwar hin zu
diesem ersten argument
würden sie sagen dass die ukraine am
besten die waffen strecken soll und dass
das den menschen eher zumutbar wäre
unter einem russischen protektorat zu
leben
also zunächst einmal
danke ich eigentlich marina weisband
weil ich das genauso sehe die beiden
briefe sollten nicht als gegensätze oder
als konfrontation oder karls krieg
gesehen sondern in beiden varianten die
intention wie kommen wir schneller zum
frieden aber zur frage ich glaube was
ganz entscheidend dabei ist ist zu
bedenken was soll am ende herauskommen
und da gibt es einige die die
vorstellung haben wir liefern jetzt auch
noch schwere waffen nehmen wir mal an es
kommt nicht vor einer atomaren
eskalation und irgendwann wird die
ukraine man würde es ihr wünschen
natürlich siegen aber die
wahrscheinlichkeit dafür ist eher gering
was wir in der neueren geschichte
gesehen haben sind er kriege die eben
nicht gewonnen werden im klassischen
sinne sondern wo es konfrontationen gibt
und am ende steht nach sehr viel leid
ein agreement ein friedensabkommen
verhandlung und unser appell dient dazu
parallel zu diesen waffen und wie gesagt
bei den schweren waffen haben wir ein
problem den fokus viel stärker glaube
ich noch mal auf verhandlungen zu setzen
und sich nicht
abbringen zu lassen weil natürlich
momentan die russische seite da probleme
macht möglicherweise auch die
ukrainische aber das entscheidende bei
verhandlungen ist das ist eine
schwierige situation da muss man sehr
viel atem haben aber das ist im grunde
genommen die conditio sine qua non mit
der am ende dieser krieg wirklich
aufhören kann würde die ganze zeit nicht
darum gerungen eigentlich wieder an
diesem verhandlungstisch zu kommen dazu
kommen wir noch auch noch zu dem ziel
und ich muss unbedingt und möchte
natürlich nicole leitl haft begrüßen
politikwissenschaftlerin friedens
forscherin sie leiten seit 2000 16 das
leibniz-institut hessische stiftung
friedens und konfliktforschung in
frankfurt
als friedens forscherin muss man die
pazifistin sein welchen von diesen
beiden briefen hätten sie unterschrieben
wenn ich einen brief unterschrieben
hätte hätte ich zum zweiten tendiert
aber ich habe ganz bewussten mich
dagegen entschieden überhaupt einen der
briefe zu unterschreiben weil war ende
dass es ein
unglaublich schlechtes zeichen für den
zustand der debatte über die
unterstützung der ukraine in deutschland
ist dass wir uns jetzt mit offenen
briefen bekriegen und eben nicht mehr
mit argumenten
denn argumente werden eigentlich kaum
mehr ausgetauscht werden auch keine
grautöne mehr ausgelobten wir jetzt hier
und da ist ja eine große moderat liebe
leistungen in der tat von frau weiß bat
die ich brauch wertgeschätzt und logisch
war also der bahn ja die türen zum
gespräch geöffnet fangen wir doch mal
bei diesem waffen bei der frage nach den
waffen an sind mehr und schwerere waffen
frau drittel hofgut für einen frieden
oder sind sie gut für einen sieg der
ukraine also ich glaube das letztliche
ziel ist nicht ein militärischer sieg
der ukraine sondern es ist tatsächlich
das militärische ziel dass die ukraine
nicht verliert und das ist einfach
ehrlich gesagt ein ziemlich großer
spielraum der dennoch bleibt das zweite
was ich einmal gerne loswerden möchte
als friedens forscherin die keine
pazifistin ist aber es ist mir wichtig
wir ist es waffen waffenlieferungen und
schwere waffenlieferungen kein zweck an
sich sind sondern sie verfolgen einen
ganz konkreten zweck und zwar auch nicht
alleine sondern in kombination mit
massiven wirtschaftssanktionen das
sechste paket ist gerade auf dem weg um
eine situation zu erzeugen in der die
beiden konfliktparteien bereit sind
wieder gemeinsam an den
verhandlungstisch zu gehen wir sind der
momentan noch nicht bei mindestens eine
seite nämlich die russische kein
interesse an einer verhandlungslösung
hat die russische seite ist noch
überzeugt dass sie diesen krieg auf dem
schlachtfeld für sich entscheiden kann
und dieses kalkül also zu denken dass
man mehr vom krieg zu gewinnen haben als
von einer verhandlungslösung dieses
kalkül müssen wir verändern wir nutzen
waffenlieferungen wir nutzen sanktionen
um das zu erreichen
so und jetzt sind wir aber nicht
besonders scharf bei den sanktionen und
benutzen die waffen ja offensichtlich
auch als ein gewisses alibi also weil
wir bei den sanktionen nicht genug und
hart genug agieren werden diese waffen
von uns ins feld geführt und gesagt
wenigstens die sollten wir jetzt
schicken herr röttgen es gibt
interessanterweise ja auch in der union
sympathie für diesen brief der
sächsische ministerpräsident michael
kretschmer sagt und glaubt sogar dass
der brief die mehrheit der bevölkerung
und die meinung der mehrheit der
bevölkerung zeichne das werden wir uns
noch mal kurz an
der offene brief an den kanzler bildet
nicht die mehrheit der veröffentlichten
meinung ab aber durchaus die
mehrheitsmeinung der gesellschaft auch
meine
da muss man erst mal ganz klar sagen er
meint sachsen es ist nicht die mehrheit
dafür jetzt möglichst die waffen
niederzulegen sondern es ist eine
gespaltene gesellschaft die hälfte der
bevölkerung dieses landes 46 prozent
sagen es wäre gut in diesem krieg nicht
weiter zu eskalieren
michael kretschmer fordert dass diese
position von der union berücksichtigt
werden muss finden sie das auch nein in
der cdu/csu-bundestagsfraktion
sind wir brauchten einstimmig ich
überlege jetzt ob es ein oder zwei
irgendeiner sich anders geäußert hat wir
haben ja in der letzten sitzungswoche
debattiert und einen beschluss gefasst
gemeinsam dann und das ist eine
einmütige einstimmige position aller
abgeordneten von cdu und csu im
deutschen bundestag es ist die
überwältigende mehrheit der cdu als
partei ich glaube auch unsere anhänger
und in der bevölkerung ist es auch eine
mehrheit die dafür ist das ist ja
bemerkenswert wenn man sich mal die
mentalität der deutschen bevölkerung
noch vor drei monaten anschaut ist also
ein grundlegender möglich fundamentaler
ganz schnell stattgefundener wandel hin
zu der überzeugung
das ist eine situation in der wir wie
sie sagen das glaube ich genau auf den
punkt gebracht durch verteidigung mit
waffen überhaupt wieder politik und
diplomatie ermöglichen das ist die also
michael kretschmer ist er hat ein recht
auf seine meinung aber die ist
seine meinung und
wie gesagt in der fraktion der
bundestagsfraktion einmütigkeit in der
ablehnung war ranga yogeshwar gibt die
hand ja ich bin vielleicht kurz noch mal
auf die umfragen eingehen denn manchmal
kann man ja dinge auch mit fakten
belegen und wenn wir uns die letzten
aktuellen umfragen anschauen sieht man
dass es in etwa pari pari ist also in
etwa genauso viele für
menschen die gegen schwere
waffenlieferungen und insofern fast ein
bisschen spiegel dieser debatte die wir
heute hier führen die medien präferieren
leider gottes ein bisschen die eine
seite und nicht die andere
kriegt man offensichtlich auch sagen
wollen wiewohl wir ehrlich gesagt ja
nicht ein grundlos eine solche sendung
machen und in unserer sendung bisher
auch nicht irgendwie immer den eindruck
hatten dass eigentlich fünf personen
identischer auffassung war ich würde
gern auch gleich noch mal auf herrn
söder aufmerksam machen wollen
entschuldigung die grünen seien mit
einem moralischen rigorismus
unterwegs und redeten von dem krieg und
würden sich in teilen auch in den krieg
hineinreden marina weisband ist es
möglich glauben sie dass das geschehen
kann
ich verstehe nicht wie jemand der sagt
dieser krieg muss enden ein
kriegstreiber sein kann
das einzige was wir sagen ist wenn man
einen asymmetrischen konflikt hat mit
einem adresse und einem der sich nur
verteidigt dann ist den aggressor zu
stärken immer
für den krieg und den verteidiger zu
stärken ein weg für den frieden
weil es kann keinen kompromiss geben
wenn es das ziel von russland ist die
ukraine zu vernichten und das ziel der
ukraine ist nicht vernichtet zu werden
was genau ist hier der kompromiss ich
bin ja selbst dabei ja irgendwann werden
sich die leute an einen tisch setzen
müssen ob es wird friedensverträge geben
müssen und wahrscheinlich wird die
ukraine schmerzhaft eingeständnisse
machen müssen vielleicht wird die
regierung darüber fallen aber der brief
den herr logisch war unterschrieben hat
meiner meinung nach der einzige fehler
in diesem brief der adressat es sollte
nicht der bundeskanzler sein sondern es
sollte der gräßler sein es sollte herr
putin sein das wäre das würde frieden
machen wenn er die waffen niederlegt
wenn er die waffen widerlegt ob mehr
waffen trotzdem noch mal die frage leben
in der ukraine retten oder gefährden
marina weisband ist das immer so einfach
zu entscheiden
ich glaube die ukraine haben ein recht
auf selbstverteidigung ich glaube wenn
die ukraine sagen wir wollen uns bis zum
letzten selbst verteidigen dann werden
sie das entweder mit westlichen waffen
tun oder sie werden es ohne westliche
waffen tun aber sie werden nicht
kapitulieren
und wer fragt wer sagt wir müssen
kompromisse eingehen und wir müssen den
russen territorien als zugeständnisse
machen den muss ich fragen wie viele
städte sind sie denn bereit einer
russischen besatzung zu überlassen in
wie vielen städten sollen zivilisten
ermordet werden dürfen das müssten sie
beantworten denn wenn sie sagen
eigentlich geht es gar nicht dass das so
passiert dann dürfen wir auch dann
müssen wir ihn unterstützen nun sind im
westen die hände gebunden weil er die
ukraine nicht direkt unterstützen darf
erinnert die ukraine ist nicht nato
mitglied und insofern kann es keine
direkte kriegs unterstützung und
kriegsteilnahme durch die nato in der
ukraine geben dh die wir müssen im
grunde unsere über unterstützung über
bande organisieren wo sind dafür die
grenzen die grenzen könnten sein dass
irgendwann die ukraine auch flugzeuge
und schiffe von uns fordert dann würden
jetzige grenzen müssen wir alles
mitmachen was die ukraine sich wünscht
was die verbündeten gegebenenfalls
liefern wo sind denn zunächst mal haben
sie recht die tatsache dass die ukraine
nicht mitglied in der nato ist macht in
der unterstützung ein unterschied das
ist immer ganz schmerzhaft das
auszusprechen für die menschen die dort
jetzt leiden aber wäre der angriff auf
polen und ich habe die ukraine gewesen
würden wir heute nicht mehr schwere
waffen reden sondern dann würde die
bundeswehr in polen stehen und dort
kämpfen das ist der erste glasklare
unterschied den man benennen muss und wo
die grenzen sind naja es gibt einmal die
rechtlichen grenzen darüber erfahren wir
in den letzten tagen und wochen sehr
viel es wird darüber gestritten und
mittlerweile sind wir da auch sehr klar
dass zum beispiel die ausbildung von
ukrainischen soldaten angelieferten
gerät keine kriegsbeteiligung ist auch
die lieferung auch von schweren waffen
ist nach dem völkerrecht kein einstieg
in den krieg nur wir treten ja nicht vor
ein hohes gericht was per rechtsprechung
zu entscheiden hat wer zur kriegspartei
wird oder nicht sondern wir haben es mit
einem aggressor mit einem kriegstreiber
mit herrn putin zu tun der in den
letzten monaten und jahren hat erkennen
lassen dass er sich für all diese
spielregeln höchstens gelegentlich und
nach seiner persönlichen fassung
interessiert und insofern sind wir das
ist bitter auch dazu verdammt uns
gedanken zu machen welche annahmen wir
treffen können über die weiteren
entwicklungen hier geht es nicht darum
zu sagen das nur weil jemand eine
atommacht ist er sich alles rausnehmen
kann das wäre ein trugschluss aus dieser
erwägung ja dann dann hätte man
sozusagen die joker karte gezogen als
atommacht und könnte sich bedienen in
der welt wie man möchte aber wir müssen
schon so vernünftig sein bei allen
unseren schritten zu überlegen wie wir
es verhindern fahrlässige handlungen
vorzunehmen und ich glaube das treibt
die meisten menschen um egal ob sie sich
in umfragen für oder gegen schwere
waffen aussprechen ob wir alles dafür
tun keine fahrlässigen schritte zu
unternehmen das ist ein unterschied zu
bin ich solidarisch weil ich für schwere
waffen bin oder unsolidarisch weil ich
dagegen bin die realität ist deutlich
komplett welche waffen und ich frag
nochmal danach welche waffen und wie
viele waffen der westen an die ukraine
liefert und liefern darf ohne dass
wladimir putin zurück schlägt das wissen
wir nicht insofern testen wir grenzen
aus wir testen grenzen aus nein
austesten das wäre das wäre fahrlässig
wenn wir testen würden wir entscheiden
auf grundlage von überzeugungen und nach
klaren prinzipien und zwar nach solchen
dies deutlich wahrscheinlicher machen
deshalb verantworten wir diese
entscheidung auch dass wir nicht zur
kriegspartei werden diese prinzipien
sind beispielsweise dass wir mit der
bundesrepublik deutschland keine
alleingänge machen denn sich zu
exponieren in der internationalen
staatengemeinschaft und dinge zu tun die
unabgesprochen sind mit anderen die uns
herausragen lassen aus dem chor der
vielen die solidarisch sind das würde
uns natürlich besonders nochmal ins
blickfeld von herrn putin rücken
deswegen tun wir
das nicht wir tun nichts was unsere
eigene verteidigungsfähigkeit schlecht
weil wir in dieser verrückten welt mit
menschen wie herrn putin nicht davon
ausgehen können mit gewissheit dass
nicht auch wir nochmal einem
konventionellen angriff ausgesetzt sind
ja und wir bekennen uns dazu auch gar
nicht kriegspartei werden zu wollen das
sind voraussetzungen die wir treffen
können das ist keine ewig währende
garantie es gibt keinen preis für die
eintrittskarte in diesen kontaktieren
kann aber wir machen uns darüber
gedanken und wir werden wie ich finde
bislang sehr
verantwortungsbewusst ab hat nicht jeder
so gefühlt aber dazu haben wir schon
ganz viele sendungen gemacht wie gut und
gerade auch die spd in dieser frage
entschieden hat herr röttgen noch mal
zurück müssen wir alles und diese frage
scheint ziemlich interessant zu sein
müssen wir alles was unsere verbündeten
und was die ukraine sich von uns
wünschen zu unseren überzeugungen und
lieferungen machen überhaupt nicht wir
treffen unsere eigenen entscheidungen
das ist eine eigene politik die
übertreffen und den flugzeugen nicht
dabei da sind schiffen nicht dabei
manchmal kann man fragen was dürfen wir
denn völkerrechtlich einer meiner
zahlreichen kritikpunkte an dem brief
ist dass die autoren dieses briefes am
völkerrecht kein großes interesse haben
völkerrechtlich hat die ukraine ein
recht der individuellen
selbstverteidigung und weil es ein
rechtswidriger angriffskrieg ist gibt es
das kollektive verteilte
selbstverteidigungsrecht das heißt
völkerrechtlich dürften wir gegen den
aggressor krieg führen eher wie ein chat
das dürften wir völkerrechtlich wir
entscheiden aber wir tun es nicht weil
das war dann wären wir eine kraft
unserer entscheidung kriegspartei und
wir sind der überzeugung dass das gegen
die atommacht russland nicht zu
verantworten ist so das ist unsere
entscheidung das zweite ist so und das
das ist völlig klar und darum liegt es
an uns ob wir kriegspartei werden wir
wollen es nicht wenn putin uns angreift
werden wir auch kriegspartei das liegt
aber wer ihm ich glaube die zweite
grundlegende fehleinschätzung in diesem
brief ist zu glauben dass putin von uns
motive oder vorwände braucht um seine
politik zu machen putin hat seine eigene
agenda er weiß was er will er will die
ukraine zerstören erobern und ein
imperium begründen und das richtet er
nicht danach ob ihr gepard leopard 1
oder 2 liefern sondern er hat sich
entschieden dieses ziel militärisch zu
erreichen und das wird er tun und er
wird sich so verhalten wie er es für
richtig hält und braucht keine vorwände
aber kein motiv er braucht er hat sein
eigenes machen das dritte ass doch sein
davon ein fundamental ist der
unterschied ist der briefeschreiber zu
der politik der bundesregierung und der
mehrheit das ist ein plädoyer für das
rechte stärken
durchgängig dieser brief er sagt am ende
ist die ukraine hat nicht das recht zu
entscheiden ob sie sich verteidigt
sondern es gibt ein universelles
moralisches prinzip dass ein bestimmtes
maß an leiden nicht zulässig ist und das
entscheidet nicht die ukraine
demokratisch sondern es entscheidend das
ist ein universelles prinzip und die und
die briefeschreiber sagen wir teilen
jetzt der ukraine mit es ist hat genug
leid stattgefunden ihr seid moralisch
verpflichtet zu kapitulieren das steht
da drin und da steht drin wenn man die
ukraine unterstützt in ihrer
selbstverteidigung dann wird man selber
zum aggressor der brief spricht davon
dass russland der ursprüngliche
aggressor war das heißt es gibt jetzt
auch den westen die die ukraine
verteidigen der wird auch ein aggressor
und er macht sich dadurch zur
kriegspartei das ist wirklich ich halte
es moralisch vertretbar weil es ist das
recht stark und das rechte stärken und
führt nicht zufrieden und sonders recht
des stärkeren führt zu krieg und gewalt
und die einzige chance auf frieden
besteht darin den aggressor in die
schranken zu weisen dann mit diplomatie
verhandlung frieden überhaupt wieder
eine chance und darum ist das nicht der
eine brief das gleiche wieder andere
sondern das eine ganz fundamental andere
position weg vom völkerrecht anerkennung
des rechts des stärkeren der schwächere
muss weichen darf nicht endlos leiden
und man darf den aggressor auch keine
motive geben in dem man sich verteidigt
das ist eine ganz fundamental andere
jetzt muss ranga yogeshwar sprechen
ja jetzt muss auch sprechen denn werden
sie hertgen es wäre gut wenn sie den
brief wirklich genau lesen würden also
sie sprechen zum beispiel das
völkerrecht lang ich zitiere jetzt
wörtlich aus dem brief da steht drin wir
teilen das urteil über die russische
aggression als bruch des völkerrechts
also wie kann sie da was anderes
behaupten und wenn es auch in den
anderen punkten geht es nicht darum dass
wir in irgendeiner weise die ukraine im
stich lassen wollen und im grunde
genommen über die köpfe entscheiden
sondern es geht darum dass wir in vielen
vergangenen kriegen gemerkt haben dass
das motiv irgendwann aufzuhören
eigentlich im leiden der menschen
besteht manche kriege waren so absurd
wir müssen uns alle nur an die
vergangenheit erinnern dass irgendwann
alle gesagt haben dieses morden und zwar
egal wer jetzt recht hat oder nicht muss
aufhören also vielleicht zielte im
grunde genommen an der stelle jetzt darf
ich auch mal ein bisschen auch wenn ich
die minderheit darstellen war aber ich
repräsentiere ja zumindest in der
bevölkerung ein paar leute mehr ich
möchte auch auf den punkt gegen noch
einmal dass wir im moment nicht
kalkulieren können wo das ganze hingeht
und wenn wir überhaupt aus der
geschichte lernen dann lernen wir aus
vergangenen kriegen die hier in europa
stattfanden christa verklagt hat in
seinem wunderbaren buch die
schlafwandler gezeigt wie europa zum
beispiel schritt für schritt in diesen
ersten weltkrieg nein rutschte ohne dass
man das wollte und genau das ist die
drohende gefahr die wir momentan sehen
dass wir bei bestem wissen und gewissen
in etwas hinein kommen was wir alle am
ende nicht wollen und ein letzter punkt
noch ich kann natürlich jeden ukrainer
verstehen und ich sage ganz offen wenn
ich selber in der ukraine wäre ein
mensch was weiß ich ihn mario pohl dann
würde ich natürlich von der welt alles
fordern um mich zu verteidigen schwere
waffen unterstützung etc das ist
vollkommen normal
aber der entscheidende punkt ist wir
sitzen hier und wir müssen einfach
darauf achten dass das ganze nicht
erlebt eskaliert ich will noch mal daran
erinnern dass wir diese diskussion
hatten bevor der krieg losging und
durchaus kompetente politiker die
situation falsch eingeschätzt haben der
krieg ist entbrannt und dieses mal
stehen wir vor einer situation wo ich
nicht dastehen möchte und sagen okay wir
haben gedacht es würde so kommen und es
kam anders ich möchte noch mal nur damit
auch jeder zuschauer folgen kann diesen
besonderen abschnitt aus dem beruf aus
dem brief vielleicht vorlesen von den
autoren wird gesagt wir warnen vor einem
zweifachen
irrtum das könnten wir noch mal sagen
zum eigenen vor dem irrtum dass die
verantwortung für eine eskalation geben
nur bei dem ursprünglichen aggressor
lege deshalb sehr röttgen gerade schon
zitiert in diese andere frage über die
wir gerade sprachen da lautet das zitat
so und es beschreibt eben diesen zweite
irrtum vielleicht wissen sie denn
und zum anderen dass die entscheidung
über die moralische verantwortbarkeit
der weiteren kosten an menschenleben
unter der ukrainischen zivilbevölkerung
ausschließlich in die zuständigkeit
ihrer regierung falle
noch mal die frage gibt es dieses
universale
menschenrecht das dafür sorgt am ende zu
sagen er sämtliche städte pulverisiert
werden eine entsetzliche zahl von
menschen den tod gefunden hat weil es
diese übergroße macht der
konventionellen putin armee gibt muss es
einen vernünftigen geist geben der das
beendet also rechtlich betrachtet nein
gibt es dieses universelle recht nicht
aber natürlich gibt es so etwas wie eine
ethik und in einer ethik sozusagen
stellen wir andere fragen das problem
ist doch nur einfach und das ist etwas
wo ich sagen würde da hat dieser brief
tatsächlich eine schieflage ist dass er
einfach moralische erwägungen und
politische erwägungen 1 setzt aber die
politik ist nicht die moral die moral
informiert vielleicht die politik sie
ist einer der der der körper wenn man so
will der argumentativen körper aus denen
die politik schafft aber politik muss
immer mehr sein als moral sie muss eben
auch die konsequenzen gegeneinander
abwägen ist es moral also man kann ist
man keine moralischen standpunkt
vertreten aber ist es überzeugend dass
wir wie wir hier sitzen den ukrainern
sagen wie lange sie sich verteidigen
dürfen ich finde das eine unerträgliche
arroganz
bleiben seiten arroganz also die eine
arroganz ist diese zusagen dass wir den
ukrainer natürlich nicht sagen können ob
sie sich verteidigen sollte dann nicht
wird dann kommt das gegenargument aber
wenn man doch in die ukraine hineinhören
würde gäbe es doch auch ganz viele
menschen die das ganz anders sehen
würden und die sich nur nicht trauen
würden laut zu sagen dass sie möchten
dass die waffen schweigen das ist
genauso erinnert natürlich sozusagen es
gibt keine wir haben momentan nicht die
möglichkeit in der ukraine tatsächlich
jeden einzelnen ukraine oder ukrainerin
zu fragen ob sie bereit ist dem zu dem
shooter ist dass mir ali
doch der punkt ist dass beide seiten mit
unterstellungen arbeiten beide seiten
auch mit spekulationen über entweder
arbeiten die wir gegenwärtig abschätzen
können mal ganz ehrlich gesprochen darf
ich mal in der wissenschaft kann ich
ihnen sagen dass es uns sehr schwer
fällt und schon immer schwer gefallen
ist den aufgang von konflikten
vorherzusagen weil konflikte einfach
eine eigene dynamik haben deswegen wir
testen keine grenzen wir tasten uns an
grenzen heran und das heißt wir
beobachten sehr genau wie die russische
seite reagiert auf unsere entscheidung
und das ist natürlich auch richtig so
und darum machen wir keine
flugverbotszone zum beispiel soll das
ist eine involvierung in diesem krieg
bedeuten würde also dass das absolut das
wird dass das ist auch keine doch gar
kein irrtum besonders sehen wir das auch
unser verhalten darauf bedacht werden
muss dass es nicht zur eskalation kommt
die wir nicht wollen könnte ich haben
eben davon gesprochen dass es undenkbar
ist dass wir selber einen krieg
teilnehmen aber es gibt andere
prinzipien und die müssen glaube ich
wirklich klar sein das ist das
selbstverteidigungsrecht sind und zum
beispiel es ist dass es nur einen
aggressor gibt und dass verteidigung
legitim ist und zwar rechtlich wie
moralisch und das wird alles bestritten
in diesem nur noch mal um es zu
verstehen ranga yogeshwar ob putin den
krieg über die grenzen der ukraine
beispielsweise ausweitet glauben sie
denn dass das von uns von unserem
verhalten abhängt also von unserer
rücksicht von unserer vorsicht von
unserem bedacht sein hängt ab in ihrer
auffassung ob putin in moldau spannend
findet die baltischen länder aufregend
findet oder nicht
also ich glaube es gibt nicht darum und
es ist auch nicht der tenor des briefes
dass wir jetzt gucken müssen was putin
möglicherweise machen kann oder nicht
sondern dass wir einfach begreifen wir
lösen eine dynamik aus die irgendwann
nicht mehr kalkulierbar ist es ist ja
völlig korrekt gesagt worden kriege
haben ihre eigene dynamik und was wir in
den vorausgegangenen kriegen nehmen sie
mal den irak krieg den sie afghanistan
wir haben alle noch die bilder im kopf
wo plötzlich die usa oder der westen
sich zurückzieht wo menschen an
flugzeugen halten das ist eine
eigendynamik die wir bei diesem konflikt
genauso nicht einschätzen können und ich
glaube der zweite und vielleicht
wichtige punkt wenn man auch war ein
bisschen in die zukunft blickt wenn ich
das sagen darf ist wir haben es hier mit
einem eigentlich konflikt zu tun einem
krieg der ein bisschen aus der zeit
gefallen ist das ist ein krieg eines
systems was wenn man so will im 19 oder
20 jahrhundert lebt aber wir alle leben
im 21 jahrhundert und im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert brauchen
wir ressourcen wir ganz andere
herausforderungen man denke an
klimawandel und so weiter und umso
wichtiger ist es dass wir
instrumentarien immer wieder einfordern
die im grunde genommen weggehen von der
militärischen eskalation das was im
moment passiert droht im hinblick auch
auf andere nationen zu einem neuen
kalten krieg zu werden also wenn ich mir
einfach vorstelle in ein paar jahren
steht möglicherweise ein potenzieller
konflikt zwischen den usa und china an
sollen wir wieder zurück in eine zeit
des kalten krieges mit unsummen in
militär und dafür wenig geld in genau
den themen die global entscheidend sind
von daher ist auch sogar die lösung
dieses konflikts total wichtig und wie
gesagt aber die sind im 21 jahrhundert
und dürfen uns jetzt nicht in die logik
des zwanzigsten oder neunzehnten
jahrhunderts
wenn das doch ein problem ist
entschuldigung also wir suchen uns doch
nicht aus dass wladimir putin die
ukraine überfällt mit wirklich
atheistische mechanischen methoden
darauf kann man sich ja gerne
verständigen und uns die hände gebunden
sind diesem aggressor
entsprechend zu antworten dass sucht
sich die menschheit ja gerade nicht aus
es ist vielleicht fatale zu bemerken
dass putin viele länder mit vielen
menschen auf seiner seite hat also wir
bilden uns ja zusätzlich noch ein dass
es diesen einen
aggressor gibt und die weltbevölkerung
stünde gegen ihn das ist ja leider nicht
so er hat unterstützung in indien er hat
unterstützung in südamerika bis zu einem
gewissen punkt und hat wenigstens die
hälfte der weltbevölkerung damit
hochgerechnet auf seiner seite also das
scheint keine ganze alte schlacht zu
sein
doch das ist wenn ich das sagen darf
immer noch ein altes muster von
territorialen gewinnen wenn man schaut
auch das system in russland ist ja wenn
man ganz ehrlich ist ein anachronismus
im vergleich zu dem was was es sein
könnte und was ich glaube ist dass wir
genau da ansetzen müssen natürlich heißt
diplomatie nicht dass das leicht wird
und natürlich werden wir auf dem weg zu
einer wenn man so will kultur einer
friedlichen kultur des 21 jahrhunderts
immer wieder mit solchen ich sag mal
alten system konfrontiert aber das
entscheidende ist wir brauchen
verhandlung formate wo wir
möglicherweise auch genau diese anderen
nationen mit einbinden ich meine der
indische ministerpräsident war vor
kurzem in deutschland und das war fast
symbolisch weil da ging es dann um
energie hilfspakete im sinne von
nachhaltiger energie und gemeinsinn in
den temperaturen die katastrophal sind
klar wir suchen uns nur diesen konflikt
nicht aus marina weisband hebt den
finger entschuldigung so ist es
ich wollte nicht unterbrechen weil das
sehr interessant ist ich würde herrn
logisch war nämlich zu stimmen ist das
ein konflikt ist der aus der zeit
gefallen ist mehr noch ich glaube es ist
ein konflikt der alten zeit gegen den
neuen und auch nicht ganz zufällig
entfesselt er sich entlang fossile
energien da nämlich der zugang zu
fossilen energien menschen in erster
linie ermöglicht diktatoren zu werden
natürlich fürchten die nichts mehr als
demokratische gesellschaften und eine
energie unabhängigkeit und den
generellen wandel von werten und normen
und darum für putin diesen krieg weil
die ukraine sich hin gewandt hat zu
diesen neuen werten und normen meine
frage an sie wäre dann aber wenn wir
sagen wir brauchen eigentlich unsere
ressourcen für andere dinge und da bin
ich völlig bei ihnen was ist der beste
weg putin an diesem tisch zu kriegen
denn er hat ja im moment keine
motivation zu verhandeln und was ist der
beste weg diese ressourcen freizumachen
und was ist der beste weg eine welt
sicherheitsorgane zu etablieren die
nachhaltig den frieden sichert damit wie
ressourcen sinnvoller einsetzen können
und da ist eben meine meinung dass wir
erstens ganz klar zeigen müssen wer
heute einen 20 jahrhunderts teil
angriffskrieg führte fällt so mächtig so
stark auf die nase dass niemand es je
wieder versuchen wird und zweitens
danach müssen wir waffen in die ukraine
liefern die putin noch mehr fürchtet als
schwere waffen nämlich solidarität und
hoffnung und
wir müssen selbst einen demokratischen
rechtsstaat erhalten und wir müssen als
demokratische länder zusammen stehen und
wir müssen klimaschutz betreiben und wir
müssen in bildung und neue energien
investieren ganz ehrlich den ganzen
diktatoren geht davon der arsch mehr auf
grund ist dass es vor ein wir
investieren müssen so also da stimme ich
ihnen ehrlich gesagt total zu und ich
glaube genau das glaube ich alle
drohungen
das leben die herausforderungen der
nächsten jahre werden bin ich das sagen
darf wir haben alle das bild vom
wirtschaftsminister in katar oder wir
wissen wir beziehen unser öl das war ja
auch die große debatte von saudi arabien
ich darf noch mal daran erinnern saudi
arabien führt einen krieg im jemen saudi
arabien hat ein unserer
journalistenkollegen getötet und zersägt
also was für ein system aber genau das
müssen wir auch aus diesem ukraine
konflikt lernen dass wir in der
vergangenheit viel zu lasch waren viel
zu tolerant waren gegenüber genau diesen
systemen wenn wir davon profitiert haben
und da müssen wir vielleicht auch
ehrlich werden damit die welt sich
ändert den momentan der verschaffen wir
natürlich sehr viel business damit
solche systeme sicher halten damit waren
wir offensichtlich auch doppelt fündig
und gott und wir erinnern uns erinnert
dass auch der bundeskanzler olaf scholz
vor einem dritten weltkrieg gewarnt hat
vor der atomaren gefahr gewarnt hat die
dieser ukraine konflikt hineinschlittern
könnte und in einem spiegel interview
noch vor zehn tagen gesagt hat dass wir
sehr vorsichtig sein müssen mit unserer
lieferung von mit der deutschen
lieferung von schweren waffen in diesem
konflikt ist das ein ernst gemeintes
argument gewesen in ihren augen oder hat
er es einfach an die kette der anderen
gereiht und es sich hinterher anders
überlegt also ich weiß nicht ob die
reaktion das nochmal vorbereitet hat
dabei die interviewpassagen von urlaubs
und spiegel war ausdrücklich nicht dass
mit der lieferung von schweren waffen
der atomkrieg droht das wäre auch eine
rechnet nicht mit einer absage gab es
eine extra noch mal angeguckt das
eskalation unbedingt vermieden werden
müssen dass das ganz gut überlegt sein
will also der text kam einem bericht
werde das nicht und es war die antwort
auf die frage ob schwere waffen eine
gefahr bedeuten eine eskalation bedeuten
naja aber offensichtlich ist er genauso
wenig wie wir alle in der lage
automatismen zu beschreiben denn wir
haben es hier nicht mit der
mathematischen gleichung sondern mit
politik zu tun und damit auch mit
irrationalitäten und deswegen gilt es
eben sich vor anzutasten bei allem was
wir tun dass er nicht davon ausgeht dass
die lieferung schwerer waffen in den
atomkrieg führt sehen sie ja daran dass
er selbst kurz darauf in einem ganz
konkreten segment die lieferung einer
schweren waffengattung auch unmittelbar
aus deutschland mit den plakaten
angekündigt hat also das scheint nicht
der punkt zu sein dabei hat darauf
hingewiesen und das ist ja schlicht eine
tatsache dass der kriegstreiber in
diesem fall nun mal eine atommacht ist
und ich bin schon in diesen tagen
erstaunt ich habe diese woche viele
diskussionen auch mit vertretern beider
briefe geführt dass sie eine
schnittstelle festgestellt habe nämlich
dass mir von beiden seiten immer mal
zugerufen wurde die atomare gefahr
die sollte man nicht so betonen von der
einen seite habe ich gehört das wäre ja
eher rational wenn herr putin so
reagieren würde er sei ja kein
selbstmordattentäter und nicht
lebensmüde das finde ich eine sehr
steile annahme nachdem wir festgestellt
haben wie irrational ist und von der
anderen seite habe ich etwas verkürzt
habe ich fast das jetzt mal so zusammen
lernen dürfen die drohung mit dem
atomkrieg die vorgetragen von herrn
adolf das sei kriegspropaganda ausrüsten
und wer sich das zu eigen mache wer die
angst in seine klamotten rein ziehen
lasse der spiele das spiel von putin und
seinem regime am ende mit und das finde
ich ehrlich gesagt in einer zeit in der
die menschen sich in deutschland über
große globale komplexe zusammenhänge die
sie kaum überblicken und die ja sogar
wir die wir die entscheidung treffen
müssen nur tastend erörtern können das
finde ich dann doch ein bisschen kühl
und ein bisschen schnell daher gesagt
ich finde heute sind andere das recht
haben sich über so etwas gedanken auch
sorgen zu machen man darf es dann nur
nicht bei den sorgen belassen sondern
man muss mit diesen sorgen arbeiten und
darüber sprechen so wie wir das heute
abend tun melanie amann hat übrigens vom
spiegel die kollegin die interviewte
genauso beschrieben wie sie es auch
niederschlägt das ist eine antwort auf
die frage nach den schweren waffen war
und ich möchte beifügen manfred weber
war derjenige der den bundeskanzler
unterstellte wenn man mit einem
möglichen atomkrieg argumentiert dann
stärkt man putins propaganda nur damit
der zuschauer das nachvollziehen kann
frau deutlich habe ist diese angst vor
einem atomkrieg in unserem land
ausgerechnet besonders oder mehr
ausgeprägt als in anderen westlichen
ländern das kann ich ehrlich wird ganz
schwierig beurteilen ich habe dazu keine
neueren
bevölkerungsumfragen ja das besagt
gelesen das ist diese angst gibt finde
ich aber völlig verständlich wir
befinden uns natürlich in einer in
direkten konfrontation mit einem start
der weltweit auch nach wie vor über die
meisten nuklearen sprengköpfe verfügt
wer da keine angst hat mit dem stimmt
was nicht damit der stimmt was nicht das
muss man sich auch ganz klar machen es
geht halt darum dass man sich von diesen
ist nicht die politik diktieren lässt
sondern dass man eben schaut und das
meinte ich auch als ich sagte dass die
tasten vorwärts gehen müssen dass man
eben schauen welche reaktion sehen wir
sehen wir vorbereitung beispielsweise in
russland für einen nuklearwaffen einsatz
und wenn wir uns die satelliten bilder
anschauen wenn wir uns anschauen wo sind
die atom-u-boote wo sind die nokia
waffenfähigen flugzeuge in russland
momentan dann sehen wir keine
auffälligkeiten was wir sehen sind
symbolische drohungen wie beispielsweise
jetzt gerade erneut die übungen die wir
gesehen haben
aber wir sehen nicht dass wir sozusagen
bestimmte verleger kapazitäten und so
weiter woandershin beordert werden wir
sehen nicht dass sich der kurs der
atom-u-boote verändert solche dinge
wären hinweise darauf dass sich etwas
verändert und dann sozusagen würden wir
sicherlich auch noch mal darüber
nachdenken wie wir unsere politik machen
und so muss politik aus sein sie muss in
der dynamik des laufenden konflikt ist
immer wieder schauen und anpassen was
sie tun kann um die ziele zu erreichen
ziele noch einmal sind eben russland und
die ukraine an einen verhandlungstisch
wieder zu bringen wäre ich noch eine
sache sagen darf eine gefahr weil diese
noch gar nicht sprechen ist natürlich
dass hier stärker wir jetzt die ukraine
militärisch unterstützen und sie damit
stärken auch in der konfrontation mit
russland natürlich immer auch dieses
risiko besteht dass dabei die ukraine
über zeit weniger interesse an
verhandlungen hat also auch das müssen
wir natürlich im blick behalten also wir
versuchen so zu sagen dass kosten nutzen
kalkül von russland zu verändern und das
ist für russland attraktiver wird an den
verhandlungstisch zu kommen die seite
wird dabei aber die ukraine stärken mag
dort sozusagen das kalkül sich aber auch
veränderungen ja es ist hochinteressant
weil sie hatten vorher das wort
vortasten verband und nach tasten in
bezug auf die ziele in diese
auseinandersetzung hörte sich zuletzt
der verteidigungsminister der usa
leuten nicht an und wir reden jetzt
klugerweise in den verbleibenden guten
nochmal über das was in diesen krieg zu
erreichen sind
bislang gilt der kleinste gemeinsame
nenner
die ukraine unterstützen gegen den
russischen angriffskrieg
erfolgreiche politik braucht aber mehr
ein ziel stattdessen kakophonie
[Musik]
wir wollen russland so schwächen dass es
solche dinge wie die invasion der
ukraine nicht mehr tun kann
unser ziel muss sein dass die ukraine
ihre souveränität ihre freiheit und
ihren wunsch in einem demokratischen
land zu leben verteidigen kann
unterschiedliche zielsetzungen nicht nur
zwischen washington und berlin sondern
auch in der opposition ich würde nicht
denn das wort verwenden dass die ukraine
diesen krieg gewinnt das ist aus meiner
sicht die falsche rhetorik die die
waffen müssen schweigen und dazu muss
man die ukraine tüchtigen
unterschiedliche zielsetzungen auch
innerhalb der ampel wir müssen alles was
in unserer macht steht tun um der
ukraine zum sieg zu verhelfen
muss erste frage an marina weisband muss
die deutsche politik sagen die ukraine
soll diesen krieg gewinnen so wie es
andere präsidenten und premiers des
westens auch tun
also ich habe in dieser sendung glaube
ich mal definiert was bedeutet
eigentlich die ukraine gewinnt das heißt
ja nicht in moskau ein es heißt auf dem
territorium der ukraine sind keine
morden vergewaltigen dann soldaten
unterwegs und die bundesregierung muss
gar nichts aber die ukraine hat ein
verbrieftes recht darauf dass das so ist
und sie sollte dieses recht wahrnehmen
dürfen und meiner meinung nach wenn wenn
ich die bundesregierung wäre würde ich
sagen ja es ist unser ziel dass die
ukraine diesen krieg gewinnt insofern
als dass der aggressor nichts gewinnt
dann sind wir der kirche wieder keine
frage sollte auch der bundeskanzler oder
schaut sagen die ukraine darf nicht nur
nicht verlieren sondern sie soll
gewinnen und wir wollen ich zitiere
lloyd austin russland so schwächen dass
sie nie wieder einen angriffskrieg
führen können würde der bundeskanzler
der bundesrepublik deutschland diese
sätze sagt nein es würde er das hat er
nicht getan und das wird er auch nicht
tun aus zwei gründen erstens müsste man
definieren was das eigentlich genau
bedeutet das was sind die
voraussetzungen dass russland solche
invasion und vornehmen kann und im
umkehrschluss was müssen wir tun um das
zu verhindern
zweitens verfügen wir nach allgemeiner
bekanntheit auch mittlerweile sehen ja
gar nicht über militärische fähigkeiten
die dazu genügen würden das
einzuschränken das kann man als
us-amerikanischer verteidigungsminister
dann vielleicht schon eher vortragen
aber was er da genau mit androhen will
das muss er wissen und was die frage des
siegens angeht ich glaube politische
verantwortungsträger bei also marina
weiß man dass da einer anderen position
ist ein respektiere ich und verstehe
alles was sie eben gesagt hat aber ich
finde ein bundeskanzler sollte nicht
ausdrückt benutzen die so viele worte im
anschluss brauchen um zu erklären was
genau damit dann am ende eigentlich
gemeint ist man könnte jetzt viele folge
fragen stellen wenn es um das eigene
team geht reden wir über das bis ende
februar bis zu beginn dieses krieges
oder über die anderen gebiete sind ja
keine spur finden sondern einfach an
dein frische schreiben raus wäre aus der
sicht der ukraine ein sieg russische
truppen raus aus dem land wäre aus dem
der sich der ukraine ein sieg ist das
etwas was man ihnen nicht wünschen
sollte oder nicht als ziel ausgeben so
überrascht dass zb alleine mit den
truppen wenn dann am ende zivile kräfte
da bleiben die hoheitsgebiete ausrufen
und einer ist das passiert was wir in
butter und anderswo erlebt haben und
deswegen finde ich das gut wenn der
bundeskanzler sagt es geht um die
selbstbestimmung und demokratie
entscheidungen die das ukrainische volk
immer und immer wieder auch in freiheit
und in freien wahlen getroffen hat das
muss hergestellt werden und die
definieren was das konkret auf ihrem
staatsgebiet bedeutender weil man sonst
soll die ukraine diesen krieg gewinnen
zwei aussagen dazu zum amerikanischen
verteidigungs ist hätte ich sie gleich
gefragt geht also ja ich darf ja sie
sieht ja ich frage mich das auch mal
gefragt und ich bin zum ergebnis
gekommen dass man sich das nicht traut
zu sagen ist eine konzession an russland
man darf russland nicht zumuten zu
verlieren ich glaube es ist falsch wir
müssen wirklich im denken uns befreien
auch ja die ukraine ist angegriffen sie
darf gewinnen weil sie sich nur
verteidigt war wann ist das erreicht
dass sie gewonnen hat da wird es schwer
ich bin an einem punkt sicher und ab da
gebe ich auch öffentlich zu bin ich noch
nicht sicher ich bin sicher dass man
sagen muss und wenn der status quo ante
also wenn der zustand hergestellt wird
wie er am 316 am 23 am tag vor dem krieg
war dann hat russland durch den krieg
nichts geworden das ist ab das ist aus
meiner sicht das klar zu definierende
ziel und jetzt ist die zweite frage oder
fange ich an unsicher zu werden ich habe
noch keine meinung gebe ich zu müsste
man nicht sagen das ziel muss sein dass
die souveränität der ukraine vollständig
wiederhergestellt wird keine russischen
truppen mehr in der ukraine
weder im don bosco auf der krippe so
dass da fangen da bin ich noch unsicher
beurteilt ich mache mir das noch nicht
als ziel zu eigen und noch
weitergehender ist der amerikanische
verteidigungsminister
dass das ist durch hier in diesem
konflikt nicht zu erreichen wir müssen
wissen aber ich finde darum so wichtig
dass dass sie diese frage aufgeworfen
haben weil sie wirkt völlig ausgeblendet
russland wird auf jahre vielleicht noch
länger das europäische
sicherheitsproblem bleiben das werden
wir in diesem konflikt nicht lösen es
wird jetzt ganz lange darum gehen in
europa sicherheit gegen vor russland zu
organisieren
auch dafür müssen wir antworten finden
georgien moldau vielleicht auch belarus
ukraine und dann muss es die vision
bleiben dass russland teil der
europäischen friedensordnung wieder wird
nach im moment nicht realistisch und das
ist da sage ich nein so aus denn das
wird nicht durch krieg erreicht werden
sondern wir werden sicherheit gegen
russland organisieren müssen mit waffen
und um dann wieder eine politische
friedensordnung zu erreichen und da muss
uns die friedensforscher helfen freitag
nochmal zum ordnen wollen wir einem land
helfen die
selbstverteidigung zu erlangen und ein
wider der nationalstaat zu sein mit den
grenzen die die ukraine bekanntermaßen
hat oder wollen wir einen aggressor
ein für alle mal eine mitgeben
also ich glaube es wäre das absolut
falsche ziel wenn wir einen aggressor
ein für alle mal eine mitgeben wollen
das war noch nie ein sehr guter
ratschlag für die internationale politik
ich war auch nicht besonders begeistert
von osten statement also diese maximale
schwächung russlands wenn man sich das
einfach anschaut und wenn das sozusagen
die perspektive ist die putin vor sich
hat dann sozusagen wird sich eben auch
sein kalkül verändern dann ist es eben
auch nicht so besonders attraktiv sich
auf verhandlungen einzulassen hat dann
sucht man ihr nach einem anderen weg da
raus und also von daher ich glaube
natürlich dass es darum geht dass die
ukraine nicht verlieren sollte das wäre
idealerweise dass wir beim status quo
ante landen ich weiß aber nicht ob wir
da landen werden also frau weisband sie
haben das am anfang der sendung finde
ich ganz schön gesagt da haben sie
gesagt es wird von beiden seiten
schmerzhafte zugeständnisse geben wenn
es zur verhandlung kommt und ich glaube
das wird in der tat zu sein frage ich
sie gleich noch mal es wird ja immer
auch von einem stellvertreterkrieg
geredet immer gesagt da geht es nicht um
die ukraine sondern eigentlich geht es
zwei großmächten um einen konflikt was
sagen sie sind wir schon in einem
stellvertreterkrieg hellerhof bezeichnet
das und sagt der westen ist längst
kriegs partner ist sagt übrigens auch
hermeling dass wir längst in dem dritten
weltkrieg sind